de mettre la table donc quelques
chiffres quelques chiffres pour
comprendre l'ampleur évidemment de
l'opération à l'échelle de la province
avant le grand soir celui d'élections
tout d'abord combien de municipalités
donc an d'élections moyen d'un peu plus
de 1000 1100 trois ans d'élections il y
en a qui le sont pas pour diverses
raisons lac-mégantic évidemment pour des
raisons tout à fait évidente 8050 deux
postes convoités des postes de maires et
conseillers municipaux 510 mer et
6949 conseillé par contre comme ça il
voit dans le prochain graphique à quatre
municipalités sans candidat à la mairie
alors voilà ça c'est des données qui
peuvent surprendre mais qu'on voit
d'achat qu'à chaque élection à des
degrés divers bien évidemment et
justement d'enjeux d'autres d'autres
données qui peuvent surprendre comme le
fait que dans une municipalité sur cinq
20% des municipalités en élections en
2013 tous les postes seront pourvus sans
opposition aucune
alors voilà en 2013 on dit c'est 53 %
des postes au total ou à peu près qui
seront pourvus qu'ils nous font face
pour lesquels il n'y a pas aucune
opposition alors pour suis un peu moins
semble-t-il que les dernières années
toute participation municipale de 2009
sas et les élections précédentes 45 % à
l'échelle du québec si on va voir un peu
plus dans des tailles en fonction des
municipalités les plus importantes dans
la province montréal est à 39 % de
participation remarquée que lors de
notre dernier sondage crop radio canada
on laissait entendre des chiffres et
c'est croire que la participation serait
plus importante cette fois ci on verra
bien le suspense demeure québec 49%
laval 36% gatineau 39 langues être en 9%
également 45% finalement c'est la
moyenne à sherbrooke cinquante deux pour
cent à saguenay et 52% à trois-rivières
voilà pour ces données on poursuivra
avec d'autres données éventuellement et
je termine on rappellera en rappant
rappelant que dimanche prochain c'est
jour de vote vote par anticipation pour
ceux que ça intéresse de 12h à 20h voilà